hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about the atimi a so this
is the a that we do a spe specifically
for a Timmy so if someone's coming at
you with a weapon how do you blend with
that so I'm going to get Josh over here
we're going to go to work
Josh all right so today we're going to
talk about the atimi a the general
overview video for this so if you start
your students off with a weapon in the
hand it'll make these make a lot more
sense to them really early on these are
primarily weapon strikes could you do
these with no weapon in your hand sure
would they be as valuable or important
no they wouldn't so just start with a
weapon in hand at least then in order to
keep you from getting bonked with
weapons or people having no idea how to
handle the weapons you can take them out
for a while so let's talk about the
three major AAS we have to attend for or
attm we have to attend for for the AAS
so we have a
yokan a
showman and a
ski okay now there are are a few timings
we got to talk about in this there's two
go no sin timings okay so one is Josh
100% successfully hits me boom we don't
have to account for that timing in the
syllabus because it's like well either
you move on and do the next thing or you
died and that was the end of it so
there's nothing really to be done about
that you messed up okay then there is I
got to do a little bit now this timing
still go no sin because Josh completes
his action it's just I put up a little
shield in there to keep him from
completing his action we call this a
little Shield UD sanaku and that just
means arm triangle so this is my arm
triangle I just have a little triangle
in front of my body that protects me
from both sides right here and basically
for something in the middle too because
with a small shift or by crossing my
hand slightly I can catch anything in
the middle as well okay so that's UD
sanaku and that kind of catches Stu
that's going to be real primary that UD
Sanu goes from up here all the way to
down here and also I can bend my elbows
and go like this so it's really wide
reaching a lot of times people say oh in
I kiddo we don't account for like a yo
low sideways strike so like a yokuman
not a yokan but thrown low if Josh does
that I just do this boom and this is
still just my UD sanaku right and that
goes all the way up here okay now for
showman and yokan that late action so
I'm super late can account for uh can
all be accounted for by that UD sanaku
so if Josh comes in with a yokan if he
came in with a gaku yokan so reverse of
a regular yokan if he came in with a
showman all those can be caught with
this and of course any kind of strike
that's coming from the periphery could
be handled in up or down so it doesn't
matter if he strikes low or high I can
catch all that with that that's our
first line of defense that we're using
now if I have better timing than that
and I can either be sen noen or senen
noen then I can do a lot more with that
right so I can not be in place which
would be good or I can blend and counter
while he's doing something to me right
so if we look at yokan we have two basic
ideas that we use for this one is the
aumi AI blend that's this blend okay and
that's where I'm simply stepping in in a
yumii with my back foot so as Josh comes
in I'm stepping right here into Josh's
space and if I simply hold Udan Kaku
while I do that I will catch the weapon
on one side and I'll hit him on the
other side so it works out real nice so
as he comes in I'm right here boom and I
knock him off of me it's super good so
that's our Yumi AI blend some schools
the school I originally learned that
called it the receptive blend which I
don't like for several reasons but
you're just simply Tak it in a yumii
okay we also have the sugii blend which
is we're here like this and as Josh
comes in boom drive straight in all I'm
doing here is getting the timing that
he's going to attack I'm sing sugii and
holding an Udan Kaku and the Udan cako
catches him now ideal in both of those
Blends if I'm successful Josh gets
knocked off of me and I don't have to
deal with him again right so if it's the
aashi blend here boom I knock him off of
me he goes back we get distance I don't
have to worry about the attack again or
Sugi come in here boom knock him back
and again I don't have to deal with it
again so if I have real successful
Blends so those a Tim was are really
successful I don't have to deal with it
however if I get caught there I will
have to make an adaptation let's go to
the other side actually just so I can
kind of face the camera while we doing
this so let's say I make a bad version
of that right so I come here I tried to
make a sugii blind was bad he's still
strong and we're up here could also be I
didn't move at all and I just caught him
with the ud Saku here but we're stuck on
this can now I have to understand Josh
is going to have a followup action so
while this is a new action I kind of
include it all in the original atimi was
because he's going to have this action
right after he does it that action's
either going to be he's going to pull
that weapon back like that so he's going
to make another strike he pulls it back
first he's going to push it through he's
stronger than me and he pushes it
through boom and he hits me or he's
going to go around it and hit me in a
new location that's basically all he's
going to do other than turn around and
walk away which would be great for me so
I don't have to account for it right
okay so if my blend for the yoman
doesn't go too well and I get caught
here on the udes San Kaku he's going to
have one of those three options if he
goes low to go around it like this I use
what we call gate on barai and that just
means low sweeping action right so as he
comes in here I sweep it down and it
come by now what's important about this
is as he's going down I'm seeking his
elbow and I want to drive that elbow
towards Josh and this makes the weapon
relative to me as small as possible
right so if it's a longer weapon of
course it's going to have more reach but
I'm making as limited as possible if I
just follow his hand down like this you
can see he hits me real easy because I'm
not taking the weapon space away so as
we're going down I really am pushing
this away at the same time I'm going to
pull my body I'm going to hollow my body
and pull it back as far as possible that
gives me the longest reach and the best
chance of not getting whacked by that
weapon right so if we're up here and he
goes low I come by like this okay if
Josh pushes through or goes high like
going high to go around we use Joon
barai and that's simply me going here
and here this basic action sometimes
called ukos so this boom this kind of
action as that goes by I'm going to
catch it here and suppress and head back
to the back side right so all I'm doing
is letting that weapon come through I'm
hiding my head on my humorous bone right
so this bone is going to hide my head
like this when I'm doing this I don't
want to leave my head poking out as he
comes through so I get whack so I hide
my head like this and you can see now
I've already put myself on the other
side of the weapon and so that
successfully gets me to the other side
of the weapon so that's our jodon brine
that just means High sweeping action
okay if Josh pulls back I'm going to try
to stay stuck to the weapon okay and
this gives us entries for all kinds of
stuff now of course when I stay stuck to
the weapon I also have to control the
inside Area because that's what I do
when I'm on the inside of Josh so as he
comes in or as he pulls back I come in
and I put this hand here that sets us up
for sumio toshes if he continued to be
strong we could do uchim marari we can
do all kinds of stuff from that action
but I just follow that hand in okay so
those are the adaptations I'm going to
make if I'm slow okay now these things
don't really change much they get a
little less complicated actually as we
go to show minucci because as he comes
in for the shui switch sides for me as
he comes in for that show minucci
doesn't matter how you uh yeah there we
go okay so there yeah perfect boom okay
so as we as he comes in for this showman
right here just stay there for me okay
same things are going to happen right
either I'm going to be a little slow and
I'm going to catch him on this Udan Kaku
or I'm going to be able to move in right
away boom that's going to end basically
in a a very direct
EO um or uh that's basically it right
enter in or I'm going to catch it right
there so those are my two basic options
that I'm going to get from that okay now
if we're stuck up on the arms either I
was slow here or I just caught it here
then all I'm going to do is those same
basic ideas if he's pushed in really
hard up high I can jot on bar pass if he
goes down low I can sweep out and I can
gate on bar and come in here right so
same basic options are available to me
less likely to happen and less detailed
than the yokan right so a little simpler
with the showman okay now ski ski is
slightly different animal I'm going to
have you go to your left hand yeah
perfect okay so with the ski if I just
use the ud sanaku and I'm late it's no
good that does no good okay even really
maybe maybe I might be able to kind of
drive it off a little bit if I dove into
it got it to the inside or the outside
either way I might able to kind of get
away with it but basically for ski I
have to vacate the line that I'm on I
have to and my udis Sano is going to be
very low and I'm going to suppress as
best as I can with it so when Josh comes
in the basic idea is this I have to be
vacating that line now a lot of things
could happen that could become a
full-blown suto moari so as he comes in
boom I could do a full-blown suto moari
it could become an Edy boom right all
kinds of stuff could come off of that
but I have to vacate this Lin on just
because I can't trust that I can knock
his arms off so it's easier to move
myself so I'm trying to move myself at
least slightly off of this line and as I
do that I want my UD sanaku in place
okay now that could happen to the
outside which of course would be most
ideal it could also end up happening to
the inside way less ideal but that
situation could happen and we have to
account for that when we're doing stuff
so inside or outside could happen I have
to get off the line I'm going to keep my
UD sanaku really low those are the
fundamental ideas for the atimi AAS
they're really simple right once you
understand yokomen you can use that to
understand showman there's only another
little idea you got to understand about
ski and there's not a lot of
complications in there so those are the
basic things that we'll get you through
in the detail video we'll put a few more
details in and show a few more examples
but that is basically what you need to
know for that Timmy a I'm Chris frines
Joshua my Sal MCD behind that camera
right there we'll see you in a future
video